you know I just want to say thank you
for giving me this
dial tone after the phone hangs up
cliche doing this is a newspaper right
has entertained the section of the
newspaper that Alonzo is reading and
claims to be entertaining is the Nasdaq
this pipe goes from curved to straight
who butt-ass didn't he win an Oscar for
this role that girl's 14 he believed me
I checked the IMDB she's eight years
older than that I know she's playing a
character but this girl could not pull
off 14 even if he gave her pigtails and
braces and a Hello Kitty book bag they
tax that ass for today tax her ass you
mean pay for education and agriculture
with her ass Snoop Dogg isn't smoking
weed in this scene okay so Denzel and
Snoop obviously knew each other from
previous encounters because Snoop says
stuff like you know so then why did
Snoop approached denzel's car with
Denzel in it and asked the white
passenger what he wanted punk-ass cop
they hired Macy Gray and said just say
the kinds of things you normally would
say also is every musician in this movie
a criminal car inconveniently doesn't
start when danger is near cliche also I
believe this at the card shown any signs
of trouble before but the first time we
see it start up it purrs like a kitten
with the nifty shot of exhaust telling
us this car is that then all the sudden
Hoyt has a magic touch while the war
starts outside
car cranks up nice here but why did
Alonso even crank why clearly left it
running when they exited the car
this kid is terrible at pretending to be
asleep also we definitely didn't need to
know how Hoyt made friends with Alonso
son that couldn't possibly factor into
the plot later or anything guy gets hold
of some peanut butter packs his ass
crack judge says oh this poor man's
insane
yeah funny story but you know weather or
judge Falls for it or not they can't
just declare someone insane like that
requires competency hearings and
evaluations and if you could get out of
stuff like this every criminal would do
it hell is this asshole laughing about
Polk I forgot about Dre forget who's
buried in Grant's Tomb
who's replaced him on the fifty dollar
bill don't touch the thing not even the
cigarettes you stamped out while you
made Jake dig those couldn't come back
to haunt you in any way okay here's a
scenario mark and Paul you kicked the
door yeah that's the first one through
Roger
opens fire hits Jeff's wife and after
our partner got shot we had time to cut
open the kitchen floor and take out a
chest of money I guess Tuco was crazy
after all the guy who plays him just is
Jesus is watching you shower Wow small
world it's a good thing Jake just
happened to stop that 14 year-old from
getting raped because she just so
happens to be the cousin of this guy
who's about to shoot him hours later you
know the business right hmm I guess
these guys really are gambling that the
Russians will kill Alonso because once
he gets the chance he's gonna cap these
fools for not killing Jake right my
guess Jake counted on the apartment
guard being sick of Alonzo just like he
muttered earlier when Jake definitely
wasn't an ear shot as we all know
closets make a great defense against
bullets damn I know you love your kid
but why is there a picture of him on
every available wall at first Sara
doesn't mind one bit that part of her
naughty bits are exposed but then later
she has everything covered up I guess
the filmmakers didn't want people
complaining that they didn't get to see
at least one boob while they watch this
it's not what you know is what you can
prove after seeing one of the most evil
cops do the most evil stuff ever Jake
makes the dumbest rookie mistake ever so
Alonso can arm himself just the writer
for springtime for Hitler live around
here
Jake's gun magically jumps from the
walkway back into his hand in the next
shop wouldn't at least one of these
shards of glass have punctured something
important on his neck or face or scalp
what he's just gonna leave him there he
can't take three seconds to shoot the
guy who is the only guy drying to bring
him down you don't deserve this police
badge cliche I win anyway I win it movie
unintentionally spawns Charlie Sheen
catchphrase
Alonzo's car is definitely crushed in
the back here but then the rear end
isn't nearly as far as it should be
later on Alonzo is clearly weary and
he's looking straight ahead and when he
pulls forward you're telling me he
didn't see any sign in his peripheral
vision that there was a massive Hummer
about to block his path headlights go
out here but then they're back on here
who's following Jake home is this to set
up a sequel because they don't do
anything with it
[Music]
King Kong ain't got on me there's no fun
when the rabbit has a gun is I'm gonna
go get it right now how are you mug the
next one will kill who's bass champion
ass
oh you mother okay
all right shoe program nigga 23-hour
lockdown yeah that's right you better
walk the world only walk away cuz imma
burn this motherfucker
King Kong ain't got me
[Applause]